From 1993 to 2000, Boy Meets World
was a TGIF staple. The show shared
a Friday primetime block with kid-friendly
sitcoms Family Matters and Step By Step.
When those two shows moved on, Boy Meets World
endured, sitting comfortably alongside Sabrina
The Teenage Witch and various other
shows for the Friday primetime block.
On Boy Meets World, Rider Strong played
Cory's best friend, Shawn Hunter.
In contrast to Cory's idyllic life, Shawn's
storylines often had the teenager grapple
with some serious life issues. He was
abandoned by his stepmother several
times and he lost his father soon
after they reunited, for starters.
“It was all the things that you taught me that
made me wonder if it was the right place or not.
But you didn’t teach me enough.”
After Boy Meets World wrapped, the
world saw less and less of Strong.
He disappeared from television sets for
years until he reprised the role of Shawn,
all grown up, for Girl Meets World.
Years later, Strong opened up about
why his presence became scarce. It turns out
the same storylines that made him memorable
have something to do with the reason why
Hollywood seemingly won't cast him anymore.
In an interview with Vice, the
actor admitted that his desire
to be considered a serious professional
clouded his judgment during his time
on Boy Meets World. As an adult,
he now recognizes his aloofness.
"I wanted to be a poet and academic writer. There
was definitely a period where I thought
I was way cooler than 'Boy Meets World.'"
As a result, the writers wrote more dramatic
storylines to keep the teenage Strong
interested in his role. Regardless of
their efforts, he was still miserable.
He didn't enjoy living up to the expectations
that came along with fame. He recalled one
instance when he participated in a Sail With
the Stars charity cruise that left him scarred.
Regarding the fans on the boat, Strong told Vice:
"They want a certain version of you,
whether that's Shawn Hunter or this
perfect teen idol boyfriend, and suddenly,
you have to be that person 24 hours a day."
Strong nearly quit Boy Meets World soon after but
finished the show's run with
the support of his parents.
After Boy Meets World ended, Strong
enrolled at Columbia University,
per his website. According to Mental Floss,
his famous classmates included Anna Paquin,
Julia Stiles, and Joseph Gordon-Levitt. Their
feature-film stardom meant he received less
attention from the media while in school, which
he preferred. During his studies, Strong stayed
away from Hollywood, only taking one semester
off to film the indie horror hit Cabin Fever.
He continued his education after
Columbia and earned an MFA in
Fiction and Literature from Bennington College.
Afterward, Strong returned to work
in the entertainment industry.
Instead of television roles, he took on more
horror films, including 2017's Borderland,
Pulse 3, and Cabin Fever 2: Spring Fever. Finding
that he preferred to remain behind the camera,
Strong also began co-directing short films
with his brother. In between projects,
he also lends his voice to narrate
audiobooks. Since his reprisal of
Shawn Hunter on Girl Meets World, Strong has
added voiceover work to his list of credits,
including the Disney animated shows Mighty
Magiswords, and Star vs. The Forces of Evil.
The next-gen spin-off Girl Meets World saw the
return of Rider Strong to network television.
Although he was reluctant to return, he said
he was able to find a compromise with the show.
"I knew that playing Shawn again
was going to be the final nail
in the coffin of ever doing anything
else as an actor, so I did a trade."
Strong originally asked for seven episodes but
ended up directing 18 of them for the show,
which ran for three seasons. Former co-stars
Ben Savage also directed a handful of Girl
Meets World episodes, bringing the
history of the show full circle.
Strong is now a husband and father;
he married actress Alexandra Barreto
in 2013 and they have one son.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your
favorite childhood stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell, so you don't miss a single one.